deux qu'on se parle vous l'avez une
lumière qui me lâche ok de quoi on se
parle aujourd'hui on se parle de ça ce
truc là gardé ce truc là ce cas là
dedans c'est juste un truc de dingue
alors ça en fait c'est je dirais le
nouvel aspirateur robot d kovacs mais en
fait c'est bien plus que ça parce que
c'est un outil intelligent pour faire un
nettoyage et un aspirateur robot très
clairement c'est à dire que vous avez
une énorme base c'est pas une base en
tête une station dans lequel votre robot
va venir en marche arrière s'ils vous
près presque en moonwalk qui va y
arriver 3 kg dans et avec des bacs d'eau
de 4 litres au propre aux salles on
vient inspiré on a différents modes on a
une vraie saint-pierre à l'arrière et
sur tout ce qui vient m'intéresse moi
parce que je sais pas une chaîne de
lavage ici mais ce qui m'intéresse
surtout moi c'est la technologie que
vous avez derrière vous avez des caméras
à l'avant on vient filmer on peut
cartographier vous avez un assistant
vocal intelligent là on va pas bien
discuté avec lui on peut lui demander de
faire des choses bref c'est un truc est
vachement intéressant c'est les kovac
c'est le dit bottes x1 turbo c'est un
petit bijou ça coûte un certain prix
ecomax m'a dit yamoussoukro est ce que
tu veux venir à tester notre nouvel
aspirateur robot jordi bien évidemment
ça m'intéresse j'ai testé des premiers
kovacs donc on est parti ici avec une
vidéo qui est réalisé en partenariat
avec eco backs pour dire vous présenter
leur nouvel aspirateur robot
[Musique]
regardez alors je vous montre déjà
l'engin de base tags à l'aspirateur
non non non tu reprends pas non oui tout
est sur le bureau si tu reprends ça va
être la blague donc comme tout
aspirateur robot qui se respecte qu'est
ce qu'on a on a alors il se pense que ça
vient sans lever donc comme ça on va
voir plus clair vous avez ici un petit
bac dans lequel vont venir vos
cochonneries mais le truc qui est
intéressant c'est comme vous avez cette
station est bien la station va venir
tout récupérer aspirer elle-même dans un
autre sac que vous allez pouvoir lire
vous videz lorsque il sera plein et
lorsqu'il vous le dira surtout donc l'
attaque on prend au repose le bouton
pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre le bouton
power filles c'est tout là c'est tout
vous est peinard vous venez vous reposer
ça lui ensuite ici ça c'est la partie
laser en fait où il veut venir scanner
vos pièces et tour perret devant vous
avez cours alors déjà vous avez une zone
ici qui va venir sans fonds c'est
lorsque vous allez bien toucher une
porte la mûre ou n'importe quoi donc
c'est le cas pour s'arrête là donc lui
décalé décalé il avance il fait
franchement comme ça ça aussi c'est un
peu standard ce qui est assez sympa et
qu'on ne retrouve pas partout
devrait mettre en place sa caméra rvb
vous allez avoir à donc une petite
caméra qui est plutôt couleurs plusieurs
petites caméras on peut l'utiliser bien
évidemment pour voir ce qui se passe ce
qui vient inspiré ci et ça il ya le foot
et des images on peut également utiliser
pour la surveillance en tout cas semble
sombrer ce bouquet et puis surtout moi
ce que je trouve cool c'est ce que vous
avez alors ça c'est les petites brosses
latérales qui vont tourner dans un sens
ou dans l'autre pour ramener ici et là
c'est inspiré mais là vous avez aussi un
côté nettoyage cas c'est sympa souvent
voix des serpillières qui sont là et qui
viennent traîner qui font leur job ici
ça vient tourner et nettoyer directement
donc on a un mouvement en plus qui va
venir se poser se plaquer au sol et bien
évidemment la petite brosse que vous
avez là qui fait son taff et qui va
venir nettoyer aspirer à tous et tout ça
plus les petites roues vont venir bouger
en fonction des paliers porte que vous
allez passer si ça bref un objet très
sympa qui rende joli service mais tout
le plus dingue ici c'est la station qui
va avec alors effectivement c'est une
très jolie bête ça prend un peu le pas
dans un intérieur je suis d'accord avec
vous mais ça va quand même vachement de
services à savoir que votre aspirateur
robot et c'est la première fois que je
vois ça il vient se garer en marche
arrière c'est à dire qu'ils rentrent de
lui même et il vient se positionner
directement pour venir tout nettoyer
optimisé ça c'est cool et vous avez ici
regardez il vous suffit de venir lever
le capot et vous retrouvez alors moi
j'ai une version tout est écrit en
anglais mais je pense que vous vous
l'aurez écrit en france et ça vous
explique comment ça a bien fonctionné et
en fait vous avez ici votre propre c'est
à dire que vous allez venir retrouver
votre bac avec votre eau propre gardez
vous avez 4 litres quand même on se
parle bien de 4 litres d'eau donc autant
vous dire que là vous pouvez y aller et
ça va vous faire quand même quelques
petits lavage donc ça c'est plutôt cool
donc là vous avez tout votre propre que
vous venez vous remplissez et tout est
là vous allez retrouver votre salle
c'est à dire que vous voyez quand même
là ça a bossé l'eau est quand même bien
bien crade donc vous venez vous la vie
dsa ces pratiques dont vous voyez déjà
en terme de nettoyage que ça fait chez
vous ça c'est quel super super cool et
la regardait au centre dre des petites
bourses est donc là une petite brosse
souvenir bien nettoyer un peu le bouzin
là vous allez avoir au plat des petits
patins tout neuf pour mettre à l'arrière
de votre aspirateur donc assez cool vous
avez donc des petites recharge ici ça et
puis voilà alors ça ça vient 100 mètres
juste au centre ici et voilà vous avez
tout-en-un ici ça c'est vachement
pratique et ensuite ses branches est
juste sur une prise électrique derrière
c'est extrêmement simple alors
effectivement ça prend un peu de place
dans l'intérieur il faut avoir le coin
la pièce pour le maître mais par contre
vous avez tous directement la et
s'assure ça vachement pratique alors
regardez le truc intéressant je peux pas
vous le montrez direct sur le site d'éco
bac parce qu'on voit des choses que je
pourrais pas vous montrez moi
directement ce qui est intéressant c'est
le système de nettoyage que vous avez à
l'intérieur regarder sur votre base ici
c'est bien le dibbouk x turbo c'est le
nom du modèle donc live ou le monde donc
il est joli glissiez ça il vous montre
qualité design et par jack johnson ok il
rentre en marche arrière métaux qui
m'intéresse c'est un peu quand ils
montrent comment ça fonctionne donc là
vous avez bien vos deux bacs comme je
vous ai montré donc ça c'est bien le
propre le 5 4 litres hockey qui va venir
injecté donc ça rentre à l'intérieur
directement entre assez cool et regardez
là ça c'est intéressant parce qu'il
vient de se nettoyer en fait dans
lorsqu'elle à l'intérieur on vient
nettoyer les petites bourses est que
vous avez juste en dessous ici on vient
les sécher comme s'attaquer tout le
temps hyper hyper hyper clean et ça
c'est vachement intéressant ce qui fait
que vous avez un système automatique de
réapprovisionnement de on enlève le
salon met de l'eau propre on nettoie on
sache les petits patins en dessous
pourquoi parce que ces petits patins
leur bout d'un moment si vous voulez
c'est chez pas à cause des bactéries
vont commencer à sentir pas très très
bon donc ici on vient nettoyer on vient
c'est chez comme ça pas de problèmes
d'odeurs voyez ça se passe comme ça
directement à l'intérieur d'une petite
surface avec de l'eau qui est propre ça
voulait des toits et ensuite salé sèche
le remplissage est automatique séchage à
l'air froid donc ça c'est quand même
vachement cool il ya tout ce que j'ai
remarqué pendant le nettoyage ce qui va
venir faire c'est que lui il va
retourner à la base à intervalles
régulières pour venir enlever l'eau sale
remettre de l'eau propre et rené toyer
la serpillière ce qui fait que vous avez
toujours des serpillières propre et vous
avez toujours le niveau qui s'est
pendant votre nettoyage ans qui retourne
à la base il fait son taf ils lui disent
rempli is clean et appareils continuent
donc ça c'est quand même cool et le truc
en plus ici qui est intéressant c'est la
puissance d'aspiration vous avez cinq
mille passes 400 voix du bois ça aspire
à ça c'est bien la techno qu'on va
retrouver ici au niveau du lavage
rotatif celle aux mots turbo 2.0 et on
va jusqu'à 180 rotations par minute et
la techno qu'on retrouve au niveau de la
caméra c'est la ivi 3d oui intelligence
artificielle c'est un peu l'idée l'idée
derrière ça c'est venir cartographier de
tout voir vous êtes votre aspirateur
robot a des yeux et il ya un truc que
j'ai trouvé une vache moins bien et
j'avais jamais vu que je trouve bien
bien c'est vraiment un truc intéressant
que fait écho match parce que vous allez
utiliser pour la première fois bien vous
avez un système de cartographie rapide
vous n'avez pas besoin de le faire
tourner et qui viennent faire le tour
nettoyage complet de votre maison vous
faites une cartographie rapide ça vous
permet d'avoir déjà les pièces vous
permet de situer les endroits dans la
maison et si vous souhaitez pour une
première utilisation ne l'envoyez qu'à
un endroit que dans une pièce au lieu de
faire et why âge à 360 degrés vous
pouvez le faire c'est très rapide et
c'est très pratique ça se fait grâce à
la technologie true mapping 2.0 qui va
utiliser le laser qui va utiliser les
caméras et qui me sortira un résultat
nickel et un autre qui est intéressant
que nous a fait ici et kovacs c'est que
vous avez un assistant vocal qui
s'appelle ico y est ko de la même
manière vous allez dire par là google
vous pouvez lui dire par exemple ok ico
va nettoyer le salon dès lors que dans
votre carte vous aviez d'assigner le
salon au bon endroit ok ico va nettoyer
sous le canapé dès lors que vous avez
ajouté votre canapé ok ico va nettoyer
la chambre enfin bref vous avez compris
l'idée c'est vachement pratique tout en
sachant aussi que vous avez un bac à
poussière de 400 millilitres regardez là
il est en train de nettoyer directement
la station lave les lingettes et ajoute
de l'eau a dit bottes comme ça vous
voyez directement ce qui se passe
retournez la liste des appareils allez
on retourne à la liste des appareils là
vous avez ici votre application et
kovacs home dans lequel et cobalt chrome
h h pour le faire en anglais on essaie
de bien parler dans lequel on va
retrouver tous ces aspirateurs qu'on
était pour la maison et ici vous avez le
petit logo pour l'assistant intelligent
que vous allez pouvoir me retrouver ici
avec lequel j'allais pouvoir venir
converser bon mois il est déjà configuré
donc on va pas retourner là dessus on
trouve des informations essentielles le
niveau de batterie il est en ligne je
peux le renvoyer au nettoyage
automatique je peux envoyer se recharge
et je peux avoir accédé à la gestion de
la vidéo envoyée par exemple je peux
appuyer si je vais voir ma vidéo alors
hop là un petit mot de passe démarrage
de la vidéo peut prendre quelques
secondes et la voyait il est en train de
s'installer en train de retourner à la
station donc là je le vois qui est en
train de bouger donc ça c'est plutôt
cool alors bon là effectivement l'idée
c'est pas forcément venir regarder la
maison de sa caméra mais si on souhaite
on peut le faire à plat arrive et vous
voulez vous vraiment mettre fin à la
tâche en cours non poursuivre je peux
continuer inspection du logement je peux
faire un appel vocal retour à la station
je peux regarder aussi mes photos
enregistrées au prendre une photo si je
le souhaite donc les nôtres al-mollah
des les petits trajets ok ça ça marche
donc l'idée et ça c'est vachement bien
c'est à dire que si par exemple moi je
suis loin de chez moi je faisais mon
application et que je veux venir parler
à un membre de ma famille au travers
d'un aspirateur robot et les voir grâce
à la caméra je peux le faire alors je
suis pas sûr que ce soit la meilleure
solution il existe des assistants autres
pour le faire mais si je veux je peux
donc pourquoi pas où tu sympa d'avoir ce
petit système de caméras pour aussi un
peu de surveillance et l'inspection du
logement peut bien faire des choses donc
c'est vrai que c'est assez marrant
ensuite je vais accéder directement
alors j'ai une boutique j'ai mon compte
à moi ou compass très très rapidement
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de rentrer
dans les paramètres pour voir ce qui se
passe donc je rentre ici et je rentre au
niveau de mon aspirateur robot qui là
est en train de là les lingettes et
ajouter de l'eau comme une marque de
suite ça prend un peu de temps quand il
le fait parce qu il le fait là vous
arrivez vous avez la carte de votre
maison votre robot fait un tour notre
maison il a cartographié il a aspiré ou
pas bref vous avez ici votre maison et
ça c'est pratique alors votre carte vous
l'avez comme ça regardez là c'est bien
écrit ça c'est la carte de la maison
c'est moi qui l'ait appelé comme ça avec
vos différentes pièces et vous gérer
ensuite ici directement gestion des
cartes vous avez votre carte vous pouvez
venir est dit et si vous le souhaitez
vous appuyer là ici vous pouvez venir
rajouter une limite virtuel c'est à dire
un mur virtuel vous choisissez le mode
dans lequel vous voulez qu'ils soient
activés aspirations et lavage ou juste
là bas on va dire par exemple
aspirations et là bas et ici on va se
dire allez hop je veux me mettre une
zone où le robot n'ira pas par exemple
ce coin là je veux dire là c'est bien
mignon mais là tu n'y vas pas je vais au
milieu hop je déplace tac je valide donc
là c'est un endroit où je ne veux pas
qu'ils aillent bon je viens l'enlever
parce que je veux qu'il a ici en fait
donc ça peut être ça mais ça peut être
également une petite frontière on nous
embête à toute cette zone là par exemple
tu ne viennent pas donc ça c'est
extrêmement facile je peux également
venir étiqueter les zones ben en fait
assigner une zone à une pièce à six et
la salle à manger le bureau la cuisine s
il est sage et plein de pièces assez
pratique chez qu'à cliquer sur ma pièce
celle là je la signe à celle de ces gens
voyaient par exemple mais si je veux
dire que c'est le salon je peux cliquer
salon et ça fonctionnera très bien de la
même manière donc ça c'est plutôt
pratique je peux également venir diviser
les zones dia que cette zone là par
exemple je veux venir à la couper en
deux bateaux hop là je la prends je la
coupe en deux tac je valide et là ça va
me faire deux hommes c'est pas avec
voyez pièces trois pièces une bon c'est
pas l'idée donc ce que je vais faire ce
que je revis en arrière et je viens
ensuite sur fusionner là je sélectionne
mes deux zones hop là cette pièce là et
cette pièce là et je fais fusionner et
j'ai plus qu'une seule et grande pièce
dont voyez c'est très facile pour venir
gérer sa maison très rapidement ensuite
j'ai une partie qui est en bas la
justice'' qui est vachement pratique
qu'ils me montrent toute ma base ma
station va l'appeler comme ça alors mon
robot aux plages l'envoyait donc là il
est un peu là il est décalé je vais
avoir mon seau d'eau propre mon seau
d'eau sale joie les niveaux je peux
venir à nettoyer l et la jette très
facilement donc préparation en cours là
il va venir à nettoyer les la jette très
facilement et de l'avenir rajouter de
l'eau directement dans mon robot donc là
je peux lui dire de terminer le séchage
à l'air qu'il est en train de faire tout
de suite nettoyer les lingettes bref je
vois toutes les informations ici sur ma
station ensuite jason je peux dire venir
dans une zone en particulier pour venir
nettoyer ce que je veux dire bah tiens
tu vas aller la claque tu pars tu
nettoies ceux qui appuyaient ici et il
partira je peux également personnaliser
lui dit ah ben tiens tu vas bien
nettoyer cette zone là là typiquement et
hop j'appuie ici sur lecture et il part
dans cette zone là ou alors automatique
je l'espère j'appuie sur lecture et là
il part automatiquement il vient
nettoyer très facilement il s'agit pour
revenir active et ma caméra très
facilement et si jaguar le plan 3d de ma
maison donc c'est un peu blanc sur blanc
dans en fait vous avez le plan lui est
venue scanner vous voyez les différentes
pièces ça c'est assez pratique là vous
pouvez venir ajouté à des meubles
meubles d'intérieur matériaux sols murs
extérieurs par exemple je me dire allez
tiens je me fais quoi je me prends un
petit canapé 2 places je viens le
positionner paris s'il a donc là j'ai un
petit canapé je peux me remettre dans la
chambre par exemple un lit deux places
si je le souhaite donc voilà un peu le
principe je peux venir à meubler mes
pièces très facilement ici je peux
choisir un revêtement au sol bois
carreau par défaut si je le souhaite je
peux lui dire également de venir
nettoyer sous les meubles enfin bref
j'ai pas mal d'options et ça c'est
pratique et en suisse peut choisir ce
que je veux voir s'afficher sur la carte
en cliquant ici à savoir les agencements
les étiquettes code couleur préférence
de nettoyage et les séquences de
nettoyage sont pas ces pratiques parce
que oui c'est un truc qui est vachement
intéressant regarder je prends et je le
monte et là j'ai accès à pas mal
d'informations je peux avoir un
nettoyage standard à nettoyage
personnalisé tu va nettoyer une fois
deux fois je peux régler la puissance
d'aspiration silencieux standard
carrément maximum ou alors on pousse max
plus ça c'est carrément gros tourbillon
le débit d'eau faibles moyens élevés
c'est très pratique et si je me le
personnalise voyez up la préférence de
zone je peux choisir où est ce que je
veux qu'il aille au début et qu'est ce
que je veux qu'ils aient voyez je peux
choisir mais niveau par exemple cet
endroit la nettoyer une fois deux fois
la puissance d'aspiration le débit d'eau
donc là c'est vachement pratique la
séquence de nettoyage également tu vas
commencer par exemple dans cette pièce
là celle-là et ensuite celle là le
nettoyage intelligent en profondeur
quotidien efficace paramètres du mode
serpillière intervalle de nettoyage en
profondeur quotidien efficace nettoyage
continuent aspirations de puissance
automatique le fait qu'ils ont
identifiées éviter automatiquement les
obstacles lors du nettoyage et puis
après vos réglages si vous voulez être
en mètres carrés ou en pied bon ok
programme elle nettoyage également pour
dire faire un petit programme si vous le
souhaitez on peut venir à définir la
durée répéter la préférence de nettoyage
automatique ou par zone mais également
la langue et niveau voyage et même
d'autres réglages si on souhaite après
c'est à dire votre assistant vocal ici
on vous explique comment ça marche enfin
vous pouvez l'activer ou le désactiver
choisir la langue le niveau vous avez
accès à votre journal de nettoyage vous
accessoires et pièces à ces pratiques
vous savez exactement où est ce que vous
en êtes au niveau de vos pièces brosses
latérales bros principal le filtre les
composants les lingettes 5 à poussière
et compagnie ça c'est plutôt pratique
nettoyage intelligent gestionnaire vidéo
ne pas déranger de telle heure à telle
absence a quand même dommage qu'il parte
la nuit et vous êtes quand même pas mal
là vous avez quand même beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de paramètres vous
savez tous ce nouvel aspirateur robot
d'ecomax bien plus qu'un aspirateur
robot c'est vraiment une solution
complète de nettoyage intelligente
connecter avec un assistant vocal avec
plein de techno à l'intérieur je trouve
ça vachement bien parce que c'est vrai
que les techno sont là pour nous rendre
service à la maison en mobilité là ça
rend service à la maison et surtout ça
vous fait gagner un temps de dingue pour
le nettoyage je déteste nettoyer donc
trouver des solutions vachement complète
avec beaucoup beaucoup de choses ici
font ça génial le tarif est quand même
assez élevé on à 1299 euros on est dans
le haut du panier mais il ya plein de
techno est ce un super produit je sais
pas s'il peut vous intéresser à
d'ailleurs dit le mois en bas dans les
commentaires et s'il vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien bien évidemment dans
la description a vous de me dire ce que
vous en pensez fine on se retrouve très
vite pour continuer à parler tech parce
que la taille en a partout et tout le
temps et ça c'est vachement cool je vous
embrasse à bientôt pour les familles
[Musique]